الصوره محزنه بالتاكيد فدوى
والاجواء والمناظر غير طبيعيه جدا انا
لاول مره اصل الى مدينه هاتاي
وادخل الى مركزها الى انطاكيا
وقبل ان اصل الى هذا المكان كنا نسال عن
الاماكن المدمره فاخبرنا احد الاشخاص قال
اذهبوا الى وسط المدينه كل الاماكن مدمره
وبالفعل هذا الكلام صحيح نستطيع ان نعطيكم
عبر الكاميرا الطائره للجزيره
صوره المشهد في مدينه انطاكيا
حيث الدمار في كل مكان
والعبارات المدمره والبنايات الاله للسقوط
مع ان اعمال
رفع الانقاذ تتواصل هذا البناء الذي
نتواجد فيه والابنيه المجاوره معظمها تم
اكتمال اعمال البحث فيها واخرجت جميع
الجثث كانت تحت الانقاض
وبقيت بقي فقط الركام في هذه المناطق نحن
في وسط مدينه انطاكيا مركز محافظه هاتاي
والدمار حقيقه غير طبيعي الدمار مهول جدا
البنايات الايه للسقوط اكثر من البنايات
المدمره في اي لحظه انا اقف امام عماره
سكنيه مائله تماما وهي مكونه من سته طوابق
مائله تماما في اي لحظه ممكن ان تسقط
وهناك خراب كبير في كل المدينه ولعلكم
تشاهدون المنظر
ولعلكم تشاهدون منظر هذا الخراب
والعمارات الايه للسقوط هي الاكثر بحسب
وزاره البيئه تحدثت انها عاينت
29,300 بنايه في مدينه
هاتاي حتى الان قالت ان هناك 6 من هذه
البنايات هي يجب ازالتها يعني يجب اسقاطها
على الارض لانها ممكن ان تسقط في اي لحظه
ولم تعد صالحه لاي احد ان يدخل فيها
وبالفعل كثير من البنايه انا اشاهد امامي
منظر بنايه سكنيه لا زالت الملابس
معلقه في بلكون البنايه
واهالي هؤلاء هذه البنايه بالتاكيد لم لم
يعني لم يكن هناك وفيات فيها لكن من
المستحيل ان يدخلوا الى هذه البنايه وكذلك
بقيه البنايات يعني المنظر البنايات انها
بنايه تستند على بنايه وهو منظر بالتاكيد
غير طبيعي ينبع عن حجم الدمار الذي حل
وحجم الهزه التي حصلت الزلزال الذي حصل في
هذه المدينه هناك بحسب وزاره البيئه هناك
وهناك 2000 بنايه سقطت
بالكامل وتدمرت على ساكنها ولذلك ارقام
الوفيات والاصابات في مدينه هاتاي هي
الارقام الاكبر والاعلى في كل تركيا اعلى
من كل المدن العشره التي تعرضت لهذا
الزلزال المدمر هاتاي هي رقم واحد ثم تاتي
بعدها كهرمان
حقيقه
المدينه خاليه من السكان وعلى الاقل الوسط
المدينه الذي نتواجد فيه وخالي من السكان
فقط عمال الذين يعملون برفع الانقاظ
والعاليات والجرافات تتجول فيها ونشاهد
ايضا سيارات الاسعاف
وبعض الاهالي يحملون الاغراض الى خارج
المدينه مشهدها طاي مشهد انطاكيا ومختلف
تماما عن بقيه المشاهد الدمار فيها اوسع
الاصابات فيها اكثر
والوفيات فيها اكثر وهذا نحن نت عن اليوم
التاسع
لازال هناك بعض يخرج بعض الناجين من تحت
الانقاض وفرق الانقاذ اخرجت بعد
سيده من تحت الانقاض وقبلها طفل عمره 13
سنه اخرج ايضا من تحت الانقاض وفرق
الانقاذ متواصله في العمل لكن الارقام
التي تخرج هي اصبحت منذ امس واليوم هي
ارقام تعد على اصابع اليد الواحده وهذا
ينبئ عن صعوبه الاعمال وفرص اخراجنا ناجين
من تحت هذه الانقاذ اصبح
صعبا جدا والامال تتضاءل باخراج ناجين من
تحت الانقاض